ich kann sicherlich immer verdrängen ich
brauche ich damit ich auch weiterkommen
das wäre richtiges twitter zitat ich
brauche dich
hallöchen freund ich wusste dass du mich
weiter schlägst du leider besser ist
weiter schlagen
herzlich willkommen skeptisch minecraft
3 viele haben darauf gewartet und wir
haben uns gedacht wir machen das ganze
jetzt mal wie immer ganz direkt zu
anfang gesagt
ihr findet alles eine beschreibung
befindet kommen der beschreibung bei
ghom befinde mich in der beschreibung
die nächste folge wird bei gomez ein
paar 23 bei mir hat vier wieder bei
comedy geraden zahlen bekomme die
ungeraden bei mir und ich würde sagen
vielmehr braucht man gar nicht euer
humba humba humba humba humba humba das
wollte ich auch gerne sagen weißt du was
nicht entweder aufregt du hast du man
kann sein dass sich die verzieht die die
world fordert jetzt kann ich mit ihm
mitgegangen jaja sehe ich auch bei mir
läuft die geht mit ihr mit ich bin der
mycroft pro was just in die prinzipielle
mitschüler also wir haben uns noch nicht
so krass aber diese karten familie bald
immer mit euch zusammen zu abenteuer
gehen wollen
wenn ich weggehe habe ich dann auch new
world order lösung wo ich bin ja leute
hast du auch ich auch was hast du auch
einen um dich rum ja anscheinend das ist
ja krass heute muss das so sein nicht
das ist was falsch ist es aber das könnt
ihr wirklich sein weil sonst kommen hier
wahrscheinlich auch nicht weg das wird
damit sie auch im battle irgendwie denke
ich mal
wer am ende mehr punkte hat bayer lueger
mercedes hat er nun doch jetzt stehen
bleibst da kann ich ja theoretisch beim
schwimmen echt jetzt ich weiß es nicht
wir können es einfach mal also ich weiß
bei anderen ist es auch so dass die eine
unendliche world border collie haben
also sich immer auch um bewegen können
aber bei mehr spieler müssen austesten
ich habe auch schon leute gesehen die zu
dritt gespielt haben auch geklappt es
sollte wohl alles funktionieren aber
wofür ist sie dann will man wenn man
überall landen kann das aber die karte
ist komplett anders aufgebaut hat man ja
diesmal gänge kommt erstmal an wo wir
sind wir müssen da erst mal hoch kommen
wir schauen erst mal wir bauen einfach
mal drauflos wir hoffen das passt alles
so und dann bauen wir einfach mal hier
diesen soul cent ab oder ok wenn es
mangels wir können ja auch erstmal nach
unten oder wollen wir erstmal nach oben
ist es relativ egal weil nach unten
kommen wir doch ähnlich oder schon mal
nach unten wo kann man sich hier durch
gremien wenig habe ich da hätten schon
eine kiste ich nehme ich schon eine
kiste ja wenn du dich mal hier in
desloch erstarrt
dann schaut danach dahin an siehst du
dich in eine kiste ich bin mal kurz den
wasserfall hochkommen in den
wasserverlust jetzt wieder zu dieser
anfang sache also ich hab im forum
nachgeschaut die erste karte war medium
die zeit war hart und dieses extreme
nahe in die zweite karte war medium
einmal die erste easy werden die gier
ist hart ok sortiert sie ich wir müssen
jetzt einen weg finden irgendwie hoch zu
kommen
schon also die haben eine wir müssen
jetzt wieder nachdenken
wir haben wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
blog übersehen die man abbauen kann die
auf der karte kann man diese weichen
blöcke abbauen nein ich habe preis
erholt sind kann man damit der hoch 03
soll sein okay ich ich bin immer noch
der nehmen wir kommen damit wirklich
nicht hoch aber wir können das wasser
vielleicht umlenken ja das kann ja was
ihr könnt dann guck mal da warum soll
zwei blocks teile dadurch dann mal los
gibt immer die blicke oder war es ein
weg oder fällt herunter nicht ich dachte
man muss hier was war umleiten eventuell
aber heute kurze blöcke ganz konnte das
werde ich sagte du bist voll anlaufen
falschen pfad du machst dir bleibt gerne
bleiben
in die wände bauen damit das wasser
umgeleitet wird wo man da hoch schwimmen
kann ich muss erst mal die world berlin
verlagern
ich kann da gar keinen bock einsetzen er
schießt wir müssen zusammen die über
oder verlagern sei jetzt ein talent der
da oben muss weg das bringt dich hast
sie warte warte beruhigt ich bräuchte
ich konnte
okay vom land hinter dir danke jetzt
müssen wir die world border irgendwie
hierhin packen wenn man es jetzt mal wcf
leute was macht denn damals hier um kopf
jetzt komme ich vertraue dir ganz kurz
diesem blog alkohol da sind blöcke
das sind ruhe ja ich wollte gerade im
block kein vertrauen hat sich zur gewalt
im staate zu der rechts man kommt er
nicht ran kommt mal dran
wir müssen nur die world poker irgendwie
mitnehmen das ist zurzeit das trink
kassiert ich habe auch noch ich habe
drei ich habe 30 33 luftballons er vier
turniere unter samen dahin bewegen oder
deko mit konflikten wohl erstmal luft
holen auch mal luft ok hab luft geholt
und zur linken sehen ja ok 321
ja wir haben schon wieder tun bekommt
ein fischer habe schwerste buch sh
wieder hofft einatmen wir merken schon
bauer ich dachte jetzt gestorben er
steht nun also die karte ist die karte
schon ein bisschen her steht ein wenig
härter kommt und jetzt haben wir morgen
auf die andere seite freuen wenn ich mir
die kiste rechts passt doch gar nicht
drin
nie konnte ich dann nicht mehr müssen
jetzt zusammen sind soll niemand ist so
freuen kommt daran du meinst du meintest
vorhin noch du kommst dran wo ich gesagt
hab da kommt man nicht von alleine du
doch gruppen an einer rotte nein ich
meine ich kann dahin schwimmen wir aber
goldnuggets fische oder wir auch hast du
das buch ja okay das ist geil weil das
restoration drauf habe ich gelesen und
restauration des atmungs das heißt
packen wirs offen hellmann dann kann er
mehr atmen ordneten sie immer so knapp
mit der wieder atmet du dumm so das war
überhaupt die andere seite wie man seine
glocke wir mit jan im duma denen da oben
hätte ich den hier mit ich sag mal ich
hab einen nebenjob dabei ja okay ich
gebe dir nochmal neben damit du kannst
du das ja diesmal bauen jetzt mach mir
das macht das panama schon
es gibt übrigens auch ein resort pack
was für diese mit haben
euro
genau das immer noch nicht ganz man
könnte denken okay ist noch alles normal
geblieben muss erstmal hier eine
hinsetzen ja du profi oma du bist
richtig gut
ja ich kann mein blog in sätzen als
heute es geht nicht ich habe keine lust
bekommen mitzumachen es geht ihm jetzt
von behinderten oder spiegelt die weiter
weg oder man wie blöd du bist einfach
immer nur alleine glory aber spielt e
mail falls es noch kein mal erzählt oder
nun müssen wir und ich hatte bleibt
ruhig stell dich mal zu mir so nah war
hierdurch wieder 3 2 1 zu dumm zum
runter rot grün also geht es alleine
darunter man alleine geht leider nicht
wir müssen zusammen aber ja wir sind die
zwillinge im land zu schaffen als 60
alter darf nur fische das nur deine
vermutung atmung zwei ja wohl kaum
schnell wieder luft luft luft der ich
bekomm ich will endlich luft luft unter
wasser
ich bin ja kein luft probleme ok 30
shows für jemand gibt's für einen
schwung
ja wir jetzt werden wir die noch
aspiration okay das ist geil da packen
dann mach ich mir gleich auch ein helm
und kann sich nun helm last eingefunden
ja ich habe pass auf dem buch was ich
vorhin gefunden habe das atmung eins
drauf ist nicht gerade gut auf dem handy
nicht gerade habe ist ab und 2003
soweit wir müssen die blöcke hier wieder
mitnehmen selbstverständlich wo bist du
ich bin hier und ich habe ja noch ein
buch warte mal ich hab auf dem buch noch
mal ab 01 auf der anderen ab 2
das heißt ich bin gleich auch ein helm
oder ich mache meine komplette atmung
willst du mehr atmen geht nur auf dem
helm auf dem kopf auf die schuhe auch
gleich die schuhe fehlerfall
ach komm einfach nur noch hälfte der
leben und hälfte der merkel erst mal die
beiden blöcke wieder mitnehmen
jahrhundert gedauert lingen wir brauchen
auf jeden fall ist gut dass du immer
schließt jetzt geht nicht anders gerade
so warten einfach habe ich okay den hast
du auch den an als ob ich okay jetzt
müssen wir weiter bedenken
wir wollen da oben hin da wird doch als
cover dabei ist auch sozialer weise du
kannst doch mit einer redstone fackel
dem gebiet tätige junge du kannst ganz
ganz kurz unter wasser rechtsklick
machen und dann hast du wieder luft wird
es halt ein bisschen blöd mit der world
border
wir müssen sie einfach hoch glaube ich
ich denke aber dass sich die world poker
irgendwann später fest infizieren wird
also habe ich so im gefühl die kann ja
nicht ewig mit uns riesig mitlaufen
also ich weiß ich dass ich auf eure
hilfe angewiesen keine spoiler schau
dich ich mich als schon jetzt eine
kleidung dieser von vorgestern basecap
tief bei 1 und waschen wasser bringt
auch nicht viel ins wasser springt hier
was die scheint einfach zu groß aber
widerlegen die skifans petting ja gut
das ist das einzige mal gönnen
lasst doch mal nach oben gehen ja wie
denn ich habe vier blöcke du hast ein
damit haben wir ein kleiner mit kommen
noch nicht nach oben
nun uns ja wir müssen sie glaube ich das
wasser um längen bist du dir wirklich
sie sicher mit dem umlenken einmal ganz
immer probieren wie willst du den wasser
um lenken indem wir was ist denn
überhaupt wenn wir du hast den atmungs
helm genau und so halten sie eine
völlige kleidung was ist denn hier immer
wieder fast allein musste
was ist denn wenn wir einfach mal wir
sind ja vorhin da oben durch diesen 2
durch und sind dann nach unten
geschwommen und herzig ist null was ist
denn wenn wir nach oben schwimmen kann
man auch mal machen
ok soll ich mal wieder gibt mal wieder
die chance hat du bist klasse komme bin
ich hoffe es funktioniert ja du bist
nicht ganz neu erleben wenn spaß gemacht
ich brauche ich die ganze zeit ist nicht
oder ich das problem ist ich kann
sicherlich immer verdrängen ich brauchte
ich da würde ich auch weiterkommen
das wäre richtiges twitter zitat ich
brauche dich bin ich weiterkomme du
musst schon mal nix meint ihr dass
weiterhin kräftig brauche dich aber dich
hier wieder hochkommen
du kannst jetzt aber ich brauche dich
nicht ich kann auch hier um verdammt als
charakterkopf sich lange du bist auch
immer man ist ja echt ein dummkopf
ja es geht nicht okay ich bin trotzdem
schnell du bleibst du denn so blöder man
soll da ist jetzt der glocke 12 cent
kurse geschafft hat und jetzt schwimmst
du mal bitte eben nach oben
ja und hier ist entdecke ehrlich ich
kann das nicht sehen weil ich ja keinen
respekt schneller und schwimme einfach
mal alle richtungen weiter so ja hier
irgendwie so ein blog
ach wirklich leute komme hat uns gerade
die weiß erklärt da haben wir im block
alter also ich komme hier klar sein weil
solche blöcke gewohnt da will ich dann
mal wieder auf dem weg zu dir also hier
kann man nicht viel machen aber
vielleicht kann man ja hier wasser
umlenken
die schreibe ich überlegt hat ja kommen
zu mir ich glaube ich habe ein relativ
guten plan
okay kommentierte mal deine blöcke die
du hast weblog habe ich nicht mehr hast
du nicht und hat noch die andere seite
hier hast du noch zwei claim-blöcke weil
ich es mag play items ich habe noch zwei
dieser seelen sand blöcke nicht nicht
gleiten doch jetzt noch fünf toren
dann gib mir den ton weil die eben nicht
in diesem ton hier
gib mir den ton mal bitten editoren und
jetzt nur ich an dieses monument alter
oder stadt doch gar nichts doch ihr
schiff monumente lied spielt obwohl emma
stone stand place und jetzt tschüss du
hast die salt blöcke vergessen du denkst
wieder an nichts was dir vor du hast
nichts davon gesagt dass man sie
mitnehmen muss ja wir sollten eventuell
alles mit dem komme ich brauche dich
leute das wesentlich braucht nicht wird
doch hoffentlich öfters volk ob ich mag
dass ihr müsst mehr sondern ich brauche
dich counter machen bitte in jeder folge
kommen jetzt hier hin wir müssen jetzt
aus einem block abgeholzt einfach für
alle die den zuschauern richtig komisch
klingt so jemand ist rauchig braucht
nicht wo jeder art entdeckt alter wohl
wenig regen laden wird auf gott und sich
auf wieder passt was ist mit der web
oder komme ein neues stück runter
hierhin kommt doch mainz wo die kommt
nicht zu uns ich glaube ich bin echt
gleich tod komme ich weiß solche machen
ich glaube ich glaube die wolke oder
bewegt sich echt nicht mehr die märkte
wir ja nur den claim mit seinem ja was
machen wir es mit bloc party klebl
zunehmend boots coots als ob wir jetzt
eine gefestigte border oder wie ich
glaube schon und wir sind in einem ohr
wir sind in einem niedrig wären keine
gefestigte oder wie kann die rumlaufen
okay aber wir können dich an die sachen
an
das können wir nicht von mir das abbauen
die leute können einfach überall rum
laufen
screenshot stellt die bilder filme die
es mir doch habe sie später im außerhalb
der boarder schwäbischen aber richtig an
die sachen
wir sind aber ich weiß nicht ist es
extra so dass es nicht extra und das
wüsste ich auch gehirn
ich weiß nicht wir können uns ja nachher
mal nach der aufnahme sessions drei
folgen auf könnten uns ja mal einfach
videos angucken von den gleichen leuten
jedes auch im team gespielt haben sonst
würde ich sagen war es das erst mal für
die erste folge
wir haben jetzt doch noch ein kleines
erfolgserlebnis gab dadurch dass für das
monument da hingekriegt haben doch da
unten stand aber ich habe das nur
gesehen ich dachte meine kiste und stand
dann ganz fett clay und dann habe ich
mir gedacht vielleicht wieder klar auf
setzen da war es dann der schlaue conny
da haste mal an etwas schlaues auch
gedacht
doch nie so und las man noch keinen
fisch essen oder so sondern erstmal
abwarten als geschenk für dich
ich esse einfach mal aus protesten fisch
ein spaß
da ist schon angetreten das schmeckt gut
also ich will sagen es euch gefallen hat
zeigt es uns mit einer bewertung in der
ich auf die projekt freut die nächste
folge kommt begonnen und danach kommen
sie dann bei mir und dann will ich sagen
sehen uns morgen wieder herein und
schiller